t
d'ailleurs optionnelle, a été
adopté au dernier jour d'une
courte session de huit jours.
Kim Vermette.
- Adopté!
- L'intrigue aura duré jusqu'à
la toute dernière minute.
Le projet de loi 4 a finalement
été adopté. Le serment au roi
enenent donc facultatif.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS ROBERGE, ministre
de la Langue française, Québec
- C'est donc important de poser
le geste que nous posons
aujourd'hui; un geste
d'affirmation nationale.
SOL ZANETTI, député, QS,
Jean-Lesage
- On n'aura plus jamais à faire
ça.
(rires)
C'est vraiment un grand
soulagement.
- Vous n'avez pas prêté serment.
- Trop peu trop tard pour letrte
contenter de passer la session
parlementaire à l'extérieur du
Salon bleu.
(applaudissements)
Le premier ministre n'a pas
manqué de souligner pendant ses
traditionnels voeux des Fê
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- J'espère qu'il nous entend à
l'autre bord de la porte.
(rires)
- Et le sécrétaire général m'a
redonné la médaille de serment
au peuple oioioiois que j'avais
laissé à la sergent d'armes.
- Rien pour décourager
Paul St-Pierre Plamondon.
PAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON
chef, Parti québécois
- On est heureuxs s s s fiers de
s'être tenus debout.
- La hausse du coût de laaaa
aussi été au coeur des travaux
parlementaires.
Le Bouclier anti-inflation du
gouvernement se concrétise.
Le projet de loi pour limiter
la hausse des tarifs
gouvernementaux a été adopté.
- On a remis de l'argent dans
le portefeuille des Québécois.
- C'est le seul commentaire que
François Legault a formulé.
Pour son bilan de fin de
session, il s'est contenté de
publier sur les réseaux sociaux.
- Ça a été une courte session
puis on a dit l'essentiel.
PASCAL BÉRUBÉ, député, PQ
Matane-Matapédia
- C'est de mémoire, là, pour les
plus ancien, c'est du jamais vu.
- Une façon de faire vite
critiquée par les partis
d'oppositions, qui jugent aussi
que le premier ministre n'en
fait pas suffisamment pour aider
les Québécois.
GABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, co-porte-
parole, Québec solidaire
- Son travail à lui, c'est pas
juste envoyer des chèques par la
poste puis de fermer la... Moi,
je m'attendais à ce que François
Legault prenne chaque jour
chaque minute pour combattre la
crise du coût de la vie; il ne
l'a pas fait.
MARC TANGUAY, chef intérimaire,
Parti libéral du Québec
- En santé, éducation, services
de garde et justice, nous
n'avons pas les services
auxquels nous aurions droit.
- Les libéraux entendent
talonner le gouvernement sur ces
enjeux. Leur chef intérimaire
promet que l'automne difficile
qu'ils ont vécu est derrière
eux.
- Je pense que cette session
nous a remis sur l'objectif qui
est de défendre les Québécois.
- C'est une année chargée qui
s'achève; une année électorale
marquée par la hausse du coût de
la vie. Les défis s'annoncent
aussi grands en 2023,
particulièrement d'un point de
vue économique.
Les partis d'opposition
s'attendent à ce le gouvernement
Legault puisse livrer la
marchandise.
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, Québe